so rate my state this is and johnny's
five seven hundred six pounds i love
that he gave his height and weight uh
reserve firefighter emt
orange county five orange county five i
thought he was for sure jersey sure oh
oh no when you put the kids in
you get a bonus point come on man he's a
firefighter firefighter firefighter
he's a reserve fighter fighter what does
that mean emt that
means he's on the bench so if there's a
fighter he's like the last one
just slide down the pole he's not even
on the pole
i think he's at home like hey dog we
need your help
don't toss your [ __ ] off man it's [ __ ]
too big though
have you seen only the brief no oh that
about the uh california fires oh yeah i
think yeah that huge like
those are he's the guy who they call up
when there's that those
massive forest fires yeah wild cards
yeah so he's not i don't think he's
working i think he's an emt
full time probably okay okay orange
county five god dude
firefighter and emt wait so if you're
reserved that you have to say that on
your pouch
like i'm a reserve yeah don't say a
pouch though so he thinks he's an orange
he's saying he's an orange county fight
i get him higher than a five i give him
higher than five
i'm a seven i would give
him an orange county a
i'd give him six in orange county yeah
i'm gonna give him a six he looks like a
seven there
yeah yeah but it almost looks like a
different guy that's that's the best
picture of them well they're
you're going to send your best and he
has that nice little salmon dinner
waiting for him i like that yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah
and he give us a side picture he's small
though yeah five seven five seven
yeah it's small hey we can't knock
people for their height small oh yeah we
do we got a duck
people like we gotta do people like
small guys for the height
well no some people like that there's a
there's a market for that like a
christian
yeah you're right i actually like short
guys better i'm gonna get my i'm gonna
give him a seven
how tall stevie uh like five seven five
eight yeah i'd say five short yeah but
yeah he's short
she said i say i think most girls prefer
taller guys though yeah
yeah recently it's been like uh girls
who are even my
one a guy who's like six one and up yeah
by recently you mean
for all like 5 10
and up not necessarily like 6-1 for a
while there were girls who were just
like
i will only date a guy if he's above six
feet taller before like if you're 5 10
5 11 like you can kind of play with the
numbers yeah i don't think that yeah
maybe
but i think for all of six as long as
mankind's been around they like the
bigger dude if you go on
any dating app like if you're swiping
swiping there will be like
at least seven out of the ten girls
let's say you swipe 10 times 6. 7 out of
10 will be like oh don't message me
unless you're six feet tall
but that's the stance i don't even i
don't even i don't even try i just swipe
left i'm like not even
not even worth it right they write that
yeah yeah of course
is there not a dating site for short
people i wish i'd be [ __ ] killing
that
actually i can't i get it chin look at
that there has to be a has to be there
for everything but minnie did what's
[ __ ] up is if i put in my bio don't
swipe
right unless you're under like 1 30.
you're going to cancel
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah it's
the double standard my man
there has to be a short communication
yeah
there's hope for me now is short
is he he's from five
short king dating yeah short king dating
it's a sight oh it's a sight i don't
want to do
hey you better get on there you better
stop playing stop playing bro what are
you doing you first updated the site
hold on let me see this tweet look it
says
it says i'm [ __ ] tired of short use
as an insult short gave you donald
glover
short gave you tom holland short gave
you daniel kaluya short gave you bruno
[ __ ] marsh
short kings are the enemy of body
negativity and i'll be forever proud to
defend them
damn right yeah kevin hart kevin hart
short super short
now do you want me to go the list of
successful tall people oh
don't do it like i mean should we do
that at that time when that kind of time
like
i mean hey don't get me wrong though
there is a lot of success well sure
people tom cruise
uh tom cruise yeah mark wahlberg
like i just said kevin hart don cheadle
i guess there's like a
so you want to go to the rock you want
to go to
but not even in like in acting they're
you generally pretty small
what do you think actors are tall actors
no they're not like huge
what is do you get on short king uh i
was like what do you qualify that
as tall i would say five nine and under
short okay that's fair
wow christian
and dude and you're going on these tiny
dates
yeah christian will be all up in here
dude so
i must be a short king five eight or
shorter or short king lover
and dude and they're lgbtq friendly
oh i like that you never know man yeah
look at that little short guy five three
guys look at gus look at bailey dude
a first responder yeah don't have your
mask on though phil
yeah chill phil yeah damn it's honestly
absolutely she's five seconds
not on the app store not yet oh
oh get oh [ __ ]
sign up for our beta and get free
premium for one year yep
but after dude short king
yeah you might just thriving oh hell
dude
i'm two inches taller than god
[ __ ] gus dude that's tripping dog dude
now i wonder if it's gonna be
regular-sized girls or if it's tiny
girls too on there
they showed a five-ten girl five-ten she
told me so there's just girls that are
into short games amazonians some really
tall
like short guys no
like one so i did like hang out with a
girl who's like
5 10 and like when i realized i didn't
like
tall girls it was when i like her and i
went to kiss she had to like
bend down or like like like squat like a
[ __ ] i was like
yeah she was like sitting like on the
armrest like out like
to get head in love with me i was like
standing on my tippy toes i got it this
ain't for me
so well your ideal girls five two five
three
oh yeah i'd go same height maybe like
even an inch or two taller
just like how tall are you five five so
if we got like a five there's a lot of
baddie five three five two yeah
which what an ethnicity are we talking
here white no
what's your name
if you don't want to deal with all the
drama though you might want to go with
the basic white me
i'm just basic white could be drama hell
yeah they're just someone i like like
i like like asian uh latino or black guy
too like i just like anything that has
like a little feistiness in it yeah you
know white girls
yeah you like short black girls huh
oh yeah yeah with like a blonde ass yeah
dude let's get on short kings only
i got i lift is a short black kings only
wait what wait wait why are you no
he could be on there because he likes
black oh god he likes short
black queens yeah yeah short black
queens okay shorty queens i'll hook you
up with my home girl she black short nah
man don't list them out stay on the app
this girl is gonna steal your [ __ ]
money apparently
i know this girl this girl no i don't
trust her man
um oh so back to him yeah i give him a
sec i give him a six i'll give him five
you know what i'll give i'm with
chappelle i'll give him a seven just
because he's a firefighter and he's the
dad
and that kid's cute as [ __ ] 6.5 now he's
a five in every picture but the one he
is a seven
he got good teeth with the nice salmon
dinner next though he's got good teeth
hell yeah
shout out to anjon yeah looks like
he very and is he italian or indian
indian yeah he could be persian oh yeah
dude and john's not italian cat angel in
that photo he looks a little italian to
me
it's just i see what you're just saying
it's just because he's tan with brown
eyes yeah he's definitely
racist where's the fence of that i'm tan
with brown eyes
some drama going on i'm tanned with
brown eyes
you're not tan i want to say tan your
ebony what else you got jen
oh chad father of three at twenty-five
wow
wow worker hashtag good guy 25 ontario
canada
father of three canada has some dimeys
guys
why does it look so different yeah well
he's got right now
he's cutting weight there wait look slow
down oh we had his girl on oh that's his
girl
oh i actually told him
hi all right chet all right in his
submission
he did say uh you mentioned that his
girl was on and he told
he said he wanted to say tell brennan to
chill talk about
my girls maple leaf hitters
i did call her kids that's also what you
sign up for
yeah when you submit your wife on this
his wife is a diamond with those
piercing blue eyes what do we give his
cute couple he gives girls i think i
gave her yeah we gave her a pretty high
rating
uh yeah remember shoot them big maple
leaf titties
um i would definitely say chad shaved
the mustache if you want to get rid of
that mustache
and get a beer he's tatted up
he's a child youth worker father three
also
fought the bow tie kind his friend is
seven his friend is a one
um [ __ ] that's great i would give him a
hitch for
his what his friend is the one although
looks very friendly
in life of the party but still in one um
i give
chad a god i can't have some dimes i
give chad a five
give him five even though he's a child
youth ontario five or ellen actually the
mustache i'll drive him down to six
i give him ontario five okay because all
right so we're doing
ontario uh i'll give my yeah i'm with
brynn i'll give him a five give him a
five
so what does that like rating big oh how
dare you go there yeah come on
l.a dude you're singing why do you ask
that question
you have some there's so many failed
actors and comics out here man that's
true
and they're good looking he's la3 but
he's a
canada five all right
cat what do you give him you're the
female here for godzilla i have never
been to canada so i
can't assess what his ontario they're
popular
vancouver toronto montreal because i
know girls in canada tend to be hot as
[ __ ]
guys don't know there's a lot of yeah
hot guys great canada
i don't think bieber is the most
attractive man oh wow really i think
he's attractive
he's short white no i like
from canada i either like really nerdy
asian guys
or like guys that look like paul walker
those are like my two
yeah paul walker before or after paul
walker whenever i love him so like
after the accident yeah sure
chris
this dude ella chris how do you know
orlando florida
do you know him he dm dm but but you
don't know him
no no okay okay well uh he's 26
who has some style those dunks are
flying jeans will fly
look at the outfit that that
that the haircut that that nixon watch
not fly uh orlando florida six so he's
six foot 175 that means he's bodied up
amateur fighter
yeah okay podcaster good for you tsa
agent come on man
come on man we gotta go through orlando
so i'm gonna choose my words wise
he got hook ups on buddy passes uh
i'm gonna go eight oh yeah i was gonna
say eight i'm gonna go eight orlando
eight
yeah i'll give him orlando eight yeah
yeah i'll give him a hard mickey mouse
eight
yeah that outfit there's pretty fly what
do you give him cat
do you like black guys that all cat yes
i do very specific ones though
like i think idris elba is fine as [ __ ]
huh let's say
darker ones yeah him uh i think trey
songz is fine i think michael b jordan
is very handsome um so there's one more
uh
his name uh romeo miller is fine there's
uh rome flynn masterpiece
from uh how to get away with murder he's
not he's not black
he's mixed yeah how to get away with
murder yeah wrong flynn
rome flynn is a beautiful [ __ ] he's
not but he's i think he's like cute
yeah he's not full uh i think it's
because he looks filipino
that's why i think he's a mix oh he's
definitely good-looking yeah
he's fine yeah it was fun
that guy is fine as [ __ ] but that's also
what's rolling around
l.a chris right yeah that's why i say
orlando
orlando eight l.a orlando eight yeah
five in l.a
i got six for la that's fair yeah i give
you six he's around here
but his passion fits out here really
well wait hold on time out
you give him a five and six you give
justin to la three
what oh just got a steep face so what is
he now
i didn't give justin the three you keep
saying that what no i think brendan gave
him a three yeah
i'm the only one with three oh what did
you give him k i think even like a four
no one was i don't think it went higher
no money i said five to six i said four
point five yeah
that would be higher did i say three
four four
three yeah you didn't say higher than
the five or six i was
not see but but i know just giving him a
three
no one gave him higher you gave him a
five close friend yeah yeah which is
fine no you
know yeah you gave her three because you
said chin was higher yeah
but justin got his teeth faced
oh justin is six yeah just in a six now
he has teeth fixed all right that gives
you
crazy points crazy
crazy ooh heather cam
listen women you don't have to give your
height and weight we're not trying to
get in trouble here
uh port arthur texas i have no clue
where that's at i've been all over texas
i have a texas tattoo
uh 5'4 170 oh you thick thick
finance major works for motiva 24.
she's on the left there she's your
sister on the right i assume
she looks she's bigger than 5'4 like she
looks tall
until your point portal is close to
dallas it's like that's what's gonna say
is
the hood shout out to porto i got some
friends out there is it like opalaca
it's kind of like that is it hoodie out
there is it it's like a gas heather
24 hour she looks nice she looks real
friendly finance major
smart yeah texas so she's a southern
bell she didn't take care of you
try to cook you some peach cobbler just
for the [ __ ] of it
dude peach cobbling a dick sock anyone
anyone i'm with that buddy yeah right
that's the south dude that's what they
do yeah i mean i was just i don't know
if she's in
i'm just saying that's the thing go back
to that okay damn that's her mom clearly
yeah okay that might be her friend
you got that older friend though your
friend has old face
so heather's 24.
5'4 170. i like how you want to roast
everyone who isn't in this
you think they're the same age no
they're not this they might be though
they might are they
so let's let's assume that the heather's
24. go on let's assume
you're probably 20 let's call her let's
call her friend diane on the left
okay so let's say she's 24. she's 24
yeah she if she's 24 she'll have old
face
face oh face god damn so you mean tell
me there's nothing wrong
but there's nothing wrong with that look
at my face
i mean you don't have old faces yeah
that was the worst competitor
enough about her older friend let's talk
about heather
all right i give heather a seven i was
gonna say seven seven i was gonna say
seven points because she
she also a good thick fake yeah texas
seven or poor
arthur said no port arthur now listen
i've been a port arthur it's nothing out
there so we're gonna do
texas all right she's to point out that
she's a 12. okay oh
but texas in general this is in general
i say 7.6 she looks so
friendly i give her seven seven and a
half all right
same i'm saying with that five four 170
girls
all i can say is wait till the next
person a word
all right veronica veronica all right
what veronica talked about oh i know oh
i know veronica you know her too
you know veronica oh wait did she submit
herself for
king this no that's a different girl
right
listen let's just pretend everyone's
trying to figure out how they know her
uh bernard is 25 billion
shout out to math bakersfield california
510 170
mother of two staying active shooting
hoops jogging
drives the hemi dodge rt charger
i fell in love when i saw her she she's
definitely a la
like [ __ ] what are we are we doing l.a
or bakersfield
bakersfield she's a 12. no let's do it
let's see bakersfield she's a 15.
she's a la 9. she's up there she's nine
nine yeah
nine and a half i just don't give out
tens around here but she's a nine she's
as close we've come to ten
correct and she's a mom as a mother of
two
too and good shape and those bakersfield
the hitters
and she can hoop with us loving
basketball kind of get on the team girl
she's super bad clearly latin as well
what you want to play for full set of
lips as well i'll play for your heart
dog she's not what do you give her chin
why are you looking at me because i
didn't because i like your face staring
at the camera i will say this
she's definitely hot right oh
because her face looks like there's so
much work done so that's her lip maybe
her lips are
probably her guys i think it's just her
lips maybe good eyelashes but something
for whatever reason when i see something
that doesn't look real
it kind of knocks it down a little bit
do you think that's the way that she
does her makeup
maybe that too but her tits look great i
like her tits i know they're not real
oh my god those are like your dad's
saying tits huh
her breasts look [ __ ] fantastic she
looks great
right here she's super baddy she can
hold bro she's the highest ranking i'll
say that
i'll say nine you say nine championships
you still give her chin feels peer
pressure to say that but you would
probably give her seven
if we're off here if you're off here
i'll give her eight yeah there you go
you know you might you know you pretty
well
yeah i give her a nine and a half but if
you see her if you still play basketball
would you give her a higher grade
if she looks more real yeah she like
yeah no i'm talking about playing
basketball and she can get down
if she sends you her best video would
you give her a like
oh i would love to see a
not a chance she is 510 though yeah
that's what i'm saying
and i'm 6'4 and i'd block the [ __ ] out
of her shot all right
she's smoking man there's that all right
yeah smoking
shut up veronica the highest highest
ranking we've had for sure yeah
you take the rate my state crown right
now girl yeah
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son